millionen menschen in deutschland haben
angst sie haben angst vor dem brief des
energieversorgers ja die preise
verdoppelt oder sogar verdreifacht
sie haben angst um ihren arbeitsplatz
immer mehr unternehmen sind von der
insolvenz bedroht oder sind bereits drin
und die die ein paar ersparnisse haben
die haben angst dass dieses kleine
polster von der inflation einfach
aufgefressen wird und all die vielen
millionen die keine ersparnisse haben
die wissen überhaupt nicht mehr wie sie
über diesen winter kommen sollen die
aktuellen preissteigerungen die fressen
im schnitt ein ganzes monatseinkommen
pro jahr auf und das hat dramatische
folgen für die direkt betroffenen
menschen aber auch für die gesamte
deutsche wirtschaft dieser
kaufkraftverlust der wirkt jetzt schon
verheerend und herr scholz sie haben
jetzt hier in ihrer rede
sich einen guten teil der zeit an
friedrich merz abgearbeitet um zu zeigen
wer hier der tolle hecht im teich ist
ich meine das erfreut vielleicht ihre
fanbase hier im raum aber es ist der
laden die langsam wirklich nicht
angemessen wo die marke
und wir stolz
die werden und sie werden nicht müde zu
behaupten dass keiner allein gelassen
würde leider stimmt das nicht und das
wissen die menschen auch und das wird
eben nicht dadurch besser dass sich da
den worten einer berühmten fußballhymne
bedienen und immer wieder you never walk
alone erklären es stimmt nicht denn was
sie hier als sogenanntes entlastungs
paket vorlegen ich muss es so sagen es
ist einfach eine frechheit und bevor ich
da ins detail gehe nur einmal die groben
zahlen angucken das neue
entlastungspaket das soll ein volumen
von 65 milliarden euro haben alle drei
entlastungs pakete sollen ein
gesamtvolumen von 96 milliarden euro
haben ob die zahlen stimmen ist übrigens
zweifelhaft aber selbst wenn sie stimmen
ist das immer noch weniger geld als sie
über nacht zu der sondervermögen für die
bundeswehr einfach aus dem ärmel gezogen
haben das waren rund 100 milliarden euro
dafür aber die schuldenbremse ausgesetzt
sind es jetzt um der bevölkerung wird
sie es nicht und während die koalition
sich über die 100 milliarden für die
bundeswehr über nacht einig war und die
entlastungen für die bevölkerung
gestritten und gerungen wochenlang damit
man bloß nicht aus versehen jemand
bedenkt dass ihrer meinung nach nicht
verdient hätte und auch hier mit
bestenfalls wieder gekleckert es wird
eben nicht geklotzt dabei wäre das
dringend notwendig sie konnten sich
nicht dazu durchringen das maßnahmen die
nachweise die inflation gebremst haben
der tank rabatt das neue euro ticket
dass die verlängert werden in meinem
wahlkreis niedersachsen kostet das
regional ticket jetzt wieder 190 euro
statt 9 euro im monat ich meine die
pendler geben ihnen recht wenn sie den
sagen never walk alone es soll jetzt
eine nachfolgeregelung kommen ziemlich
kompliziert und vor allem soll sie über
die länder mitfinanziert werden sie
wissen aber dass viele länder das
finanziell überhaupt nicht stimmen
können das doch eine luftnummer dass die
wahrheit
und ich meine
sie stellen sich hier erst sagt hin und
versuchen das als großen sozialen wusste
verkaufen dass sie den rentnerinnen und
rentnern nach massivem druck von uns von
der linken von sozialverbänden von der
öffentlichkeit endlich auch das mickrige
energie geld von 300 euro zukommen
lassen wollen studierende trinken sogar
nur 200 euro beides reicht überhaupt
nicht aus und die tatsächlichen teuro
abzufangen das ist doch einfach nur ein
witz kolleginnen und kollegen kommen wir
mal zum kindergeld
18 euro erhöhung 18 euro erhöhung der
wahnsinnig macht ihnen das nicht
peinlich
im koalitionsvertrag steht die
kindergrundsicherung drin die kommt
nicht stattdessen kommt diese
lächerliche erhöhung die speisen das in
die entlastungs päckchen rein damit sie
behaupten können für kinder wäre auch
fast drin ich mein wissen sie eigentlich
wie viel teurer schulhefte stifte und
andere notwendige dinge geworden sind
jetzt zum schulanfang ist das für viele
familien ein echtes problem sich das
leisten zu können das ist die wahrheit
die lebensmittelpreise sind im letzten
jahr im schnitt um 20 prozent gestiegen
die kindergelderhöhung macht nicht mal
zehn prozent aus und das heißt das heißt
dass die eltern das kindergeld brauchen
wir den monat zu kommen das sie jetzt
bei sich sparen müssen um ihre kinder
noch ernähren zu können das ist bereits
jetzt die realität in vielen familien
was machen sie denn wie gut das bei
denen ankommt wenn sie immer wieder
sagen you never walk alone und kommen
wir jetzt zum bürger gilt ich meine das
klingt vielleicht besser aber es ist
leider nichts anderes als hartz4 hat
vier für arme das leider wörtlich
gemeint die erhöhung von 50 euro ist
nicht mal der inflationsausgleich nicht
mal ansatzweise das ist in wirklichkeit
überhaupt keine erhöhung die menschen in
grundsicherung werden weiter von ihrer
politik abgehängt das ist die wahrheit
und was sagen sie all den vielen die
seit jahren gezwungen sind bei der tafel
anzustreben und die jetzt nicht einmal
mehr dort genug lebensmittel kriegen
weil die tafeln auch unter druck sind
stellen sie sich daneben und so haben
sie den schon hervorlocken ich glaub
nicht das betrifft inzwischen schon zwei
millionen menschen in unserem land die
müssen zur tafel die tendenz ist steigt
laut dem forschungsinstitut für
wärmeschutz in münchen müssen menschen
in schlecht gedämmten wohnungen bei den
aktuellen preisen bereits und
energiekosten von rund 4500 euro pro
jahr rechnen letztes jahr waren das noch
1800 die kosten haben sich mehr als
verdoppelt in einfamilienhäusern
auch wenn sie gedämmt sind steigen die
energiekosten von 2800 auf
7200 euro pro jahr diese preis explosion
die muss gestoppt werden aber leider tun
sie das nicht und ihre angekündigte
strompreis bremse ist leider jetzt schon
eine luftnummer einmal weil die teuerung
eben nicht nur den strombereich
betreffen sondern den gesamten
energiebereich aber vor allem weil diese
strompreis bremse nur dann kommen soll
wenn sie gegenfinanziert wird über eine
über den steuer die wiederum davon
abhängt dass die eu-kommission dafür
grünes licht gibt andere länder haben
das längst ein gefühl dann über gewinnt
steuer warum verstecken sie sich hinter
brüssel die man sie sagen erst wenn es
in brüssel nicht klappt dann wird eine
nationale regelung erwogen ich meine sie
tun ja so als hätte die lösung dieser
probleme noch ewig zeit nein die
menschen brauchen jetzt die
unterstützung
und darum
wären auch direktzahlungen jetzt wichtig
die wirklich wirkung entfalten wir
fordern mindestens 125 euro pro monat
also 1500 euro pro jahr für jeden
haushalt mit kleinem und mittleren
einkommen denn der kaufkraftverlust ist
vergeben immer mehr betriebe bäckereien
friseure die die preise aufgrund der
steigenden kosten erhöhen mussten die
sehen dass ihnen die kunden wegbrechen
weil sie einfach nicht mehr das geld
haben da hin zu tun der chef des ifo
institutes clemens fuest der sagte über
die maßnahmen der bundesregierung dass
sie die rezession nicht verhindert
werden in diesem winter ein
vernichtendes urteil
das institut für deutsche wirtschaft
rechnet damit dass es bei den steigenden
preisen
300.000 zusätzliche arbeitslose im jahr
2023 geben wird ich meine haben wir den
mitarbeitern den job center schon durch
gestellt was in den verzweifelten
menschen von ihnen ausrichten sollen
never walk alone man sagen sie den frust
irgendwann kommt vielleicht mal eine
strompreis bremse wenn brüssel mitspielt
das reicht nicht kolleginnen und
kollegen dieser energiemarkt der muss
reguliert werden das ist die wahrheit
und meine wenn man einmal gesehen hat
dass der markt ist nicht richtet dann
doch jetzt wir brauchen eine
funktionierende staatliche preisaufsicht
und wir brauchen eben auch einen preis
deckel für die gesamte energie für die
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher
das bringt
in frankreich wurde ein preis deckel
eingeführt da übernimmt der staat die
differenz zwischen den festgelegten
verbrauchspreis und den tatsächlichen
marktpreis warum geht das nicht bei uns
und ja ich weiß ja ich weiß ja die
antwort dafür ist angeblich kein geld da
denn es gibt ja die schuldenbremse das
lieblingskind von herrn lindner und ich
möchte ihnen mal sagen wenn sie trotz
dieser historischen krise lieber an
ihrem fetisch schuldenbremse festhalten
wollen anstatt zu verhindern dass immer
größere teil der bevölkerung in die
armut getrieben werden dann ist das
einfach nur verantwortungslos wenn die
box die historischen krise die
bevölkerung in ihrer breite trifft nicht
einmal darüber nachdenken die
vermögenssteuer wieder einzuführen die
spd und grüne das noch im wahlprogramm
hatten dann ist auch das einfach nur
verantwortungslos ich meine wenn nicht
jetzt wann dann bitte
in dieser lage an der von allen menschen
solidarität erwartet würden den
angeblich alle den gürtel enger
schnallen sollen nicht dafür zu sorgen
dass diejenigen mit dem weitesten gürtel
den das überhaupt nicht weh tun würde
wenn sie ein bisschen enger schnallen
würden die teilweise ihr vermögen in der
krise noch sagt vermehren konnten die
multi millionäre die milliardäre wenn
sie jetzt nicht dafür sorgen dass die
sich zumindest ein stück weit angemessen
an den krisenkosten beteiligen dann
fällt mir wirklich absolut nichts mehr
dazu einfach inakzeptabel so unsozial
das nichts zu tun
natürlich darf man bei alldem nicht
vergessen dass die preis explosion durch
den russischen angriffskrieg auf die
ukraine verursacht worden ist dieser
angriffskrieg der kann nicht akzeptiert
werden man musste darauf reagieren wir
als linke unterstützen die sanktionen
gegen putins machtapparat gegen die
mächtigen musikalischen gegen die
russische rüstungsindustrie
was wir aber kritisieren das sind
sanktionen die hauptsächlich die
russische bevölkerung treffen und die in
deutschland in europa im globalen süden
mehr schaden anrichten als bei den den
man eigentlich schaden soll sie nämlich
putins kriegsmaschinen wir stellen aber
fest die kriegsmaschinerie rollt
unbeeindruckt von europäischen
sanktionen leider weiter in ländern des
globalen südens gibt es bereits
ernsthafte versorgungslücken weil sie
beim weltweiten preiskampf um das erdgas
eben nicht mithalten können und auch
hier bei uns drohen weitere extreme
preissteigerungen ebenfalls
versorgungslücken beides wird zum
wegbrechen ganzer industriezweige führen
das darf man nicht geschehen lassen
kolleginnen kollegen
darum
fordern wir von der bundesregierung vor
es muss alles unternommen werden um auf
diplomatischen wege einen sofortigen
waffenstillstand zu erreichen damit
friedensverhandlungen beginnen können
dieser krieg muss so schnell wie möglich
ändern und zweitens
sie müssen mit russland in verhandlungen
über die gaslieferungen treten und die
versorgungssicherheit zu gewährleisten
das erwarte die bevölkerung zu recht ich
nehme sie beim wort herr scholz die
haben gesagt die sanktionen dürfen
europa nicht härter treffen als russland
bitte handeln sie mir sprechen dank
[Applaus]